bonjour antoine quels sont les enjeux de
cette visite de sergueï lavrov
aujourd'hui en egypte ouais bien
l'égypte considéré comme un partenaire
stratégique de la russie au moyen-orient
fait aujourd'hui l'objet de ce
déplacement de sergey lavrov il
rencontrera son homologue mais aussi le
président égyptien d'el fattah al-sisi
il sera question de renforcer les liens
commerciaux et économiques entre les
deux pays et ce dans différents domaines
sanitaire militaires ou encore
énergétique il symbole de cette
coopération c'est la construction de la
première centrale centrales nucléaires
russes
en egypte des sujets d'actualité de la
région tels que la syrie la libye ainsi
que la palestine seront eux aussi abordé
l'egypte si vous l'avez évoqué compte
également demander la médiation de la
russie dans la crise du barrage de la
renaissance un barrage sur le nil situés
en ethiopie dont la gestion cause des
tensions entre le caire et addis abeba
et pour terminer sergueï lavrov a fait
savoir que les vols directs vers les
stations balnéaires égyptiennes pourrait
bientôt reprendre ce qui constituerait
une bonne nouvelle pour le secteur
touristique égyptien
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions antoine gayraud en direct de
moscou